NARRATOR: WITH A
FIRE AT ITS HEART...
YELLOWSTONE IS OUR
FIRST NATIONAL PARK...
A PRIMAL FORTRESS THAT
SAVED THE DISAPPEARING WEST...
THANKS TO ITS FIERCE WONDERS.
MORE THAN THREE MILLION
VISITORS A YEAR COME TO MARVEL.
BUT ONLY A HANDFUL
VENTURE PAST THE LOOKOUTS.
OVER THAT RIDGE AND INTO
THE NEXT VALLEY IS WHERE
THE REAL DRAMA HAPPENS.
OLD BATTLES...
NEW LIFE...
AND UNEXPECTED COURAGE...
IF YOU THINK YOU
KNOW YELLOWSTONE...
THINK AGAIN...
YOU HAVE NEVER
EXPERIENCED IT LIKE THIS.
♪ [THEME MUSIC PLAYS] ♪
♪ ♪
IN THE SHADOW OF THE ROCKIES,
AN ANCIENT DRAMA
IS ABOUT TO PLAY OUT....
ONE THAT NEARLY DISAPPEARED
FROM THE FACE OF THE EARTH:
YELLOWSTONE'S TOP PREDATOR
AGAINST THE LARGEST MAMMAL
IN NORTH AMERICA.
ONCE ONLY 23
BISON REMAINED HERE.
AND NOT A SINGLE WOLF.
BUT NOW THESE ETERNAL
ENEMIES FACE OFF AGAIN...
AS THEY DID LONG BEFORE
ANY HUMAN SET FOOT HERE.
YELLOWSTONE HAS
TURNED BACK TIME.
IT'S LATE WINTER IN
AMERICA'S FIRST NATIONAL PARK,
AND THE WORLD'S.
YELLOWSTONE IS A MELTING POT
OF SAVAGE BEAUTY CREATED BY
ONE OF THE BIGGEST EXPLOSIONS
EVER TO ROCK THE EARTH.
AND ITS VIOLENT
HEART STILL SMOLDERS...
BLOWING OFF STEAM
THROUGH SOME 300 GEYSERS...
MORE THAN ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE WORLD.
THE MOST FAMOUS GEYSER,
OLD FAITHFUL,
HURLS HOT WATER 150 FEET
INTO THE AIR VENTING ITS RAGE
EVERY 60 TO 90 MINUTES.
THAT'S HOW LONG IT TAKES
TO BUILD UP ENOUGH PRESSURE
TO TURN GROUNDWATER
INTO EXPLOSIVE STEAM.
SOME BISON TAKE REFUGE IN
THE STINKING SULFUROUS HEAT...
A LAST HAVEN FOR
THE WEAK AND WEARY.
BUT ELSEWHERE IN THE PARK,
THEY MUST FACE THE
BRUTAL WINTER HEAD-ON.
MOTHERS-TO-BE
STRUGGLE TERRIBLY,
TRYING TO FIND ENOUGH FOOD
FOR TWO IN THE RELENTLESS SNOW.
THE CALF SHE CARRIES IS A
REMINDER OF A MIRACULOUS
COMEBACK, IF SHE CAN HOLD
ON THROUGH YELLOWSTONE'S
NOTORIOUSLY HARSH WINTER.
BUT SPRING IS LATE THIS YEAR,
TEMPERATURES HOVER WELL
BELOW FREEZING AND THE SNOWPACK
DOES NOT GIVE WAY.
THE GRAZING ANIMALS MUST
STRUGGLE MIGHTILY IN SEARCH OF
A FEW BLADES OF GRASS.
MANY ELK GROW WEAK
AS WINTER DRAGS ON...
BUT SOMEONE ELSE GROWS STRONG.
THE WOLF THRIVES IN WINTER.
HIGHLY INTELLIGENT
AND SOCIAL CREATURES,
THEY OFTEN SHOW DEEP
AFFECTION FOR ONE ANOTHER.
THEIR INTENSE FAMILY
TIES ALSO MAKE THEM A
DEADLY HUNTING UNIT.
ONCE COMPLETELY
EXTERMINATED FROM THE PARK,
GRAY WOLVES WERE
REINTRODUCED IN 1995 AND
HAVE BECOME A VITAL PLAYER
IN THE PARK'S ECOSYSTEM.
EAGERLY CHASING
A BIG BULL ELK,
THE WOLF IS IN ITS
ELEMENT IN YELLOWSTONE.
♪ ♪
BUT THIS BULL DIDN'T EARN HIS
RACK BY BEING ANYONE'S FOOL.
HE FINDS REFUGE IN
THE FRIGID LAMAR RIVER,
WHERE THE WOLVES
CANNOT FOLLOW.
AND AIMS HIS
IMPRESSIVE RACK AT THEM.
[HOWL]
BUT ANOTHER DINNER AWAITS...
AS THE REST OF
THE PACK ANNOUNCES.
THEY'VE TAKEN A WEAKENED
BISON DURING THE NIGHT AND
THERE'S MORE THAN
ENOUGH TO GO AROUND.
WITH SUCH A
LARGE PACK TO FEED,
THEY NEED TO HUNT
SUCCESSFULLY NEARLY EVERY DAY.
BUT THE WINTER ITSELF IS
FAR MORE DEADLY THAN WOLVES.
ONE OUT OF TEN BISON WILL
DIE BEFORE THE SEASON IS DONE.
FOR OUR MOTHER-TO-BE IT
IS A PARTICULARLY HARD TIME.
THE SCARCITY OF FOOD
MEANS MANY ARE STARVING.
WITH WEARY, MASSIVE HEADS,
THEY PLOW THROUGH 4-FOOT
DRIFTS IN SEARCH
OF ANYTHING EDIBLE.
THEY ARE THE LAST TRULY WILD
BISON IN THE UNITED STATES.
SOME 30 MILLION OF THEM ONCE
BLANKETED THE AMERICAN PLAINS;
IT COULD TAKE SIX DAYS FOR
A SINGLE HERD TO PASS YOU BY.
BUT BY 1900, ONLY A
HEARTBREAKING TWO DOZEN
CLUNG TO LIFE IN THE
CENTER OF THE PARK,
THE LAST REFUGEES OF A
CENTURY OF PERSECUTION.
PROTECTED IN 1902,
THEY'VE SLOWLY REBOUNDED TO
ABOUT 5,000 TODAY.
BUT IN A TERRIBLE WINTER,
THEIR NUMBERS COULD CRASH.
WITH THE BISON
CARCASS PICKED CLEAN,
THE LAMAR WOLF PACK'S
SPECTACULAR ALPHA FEMALE IS ON
THE LOOKOUT FOR MORE MEAT.
AND AN ELK CALF HAS
STRAYED FROM ITS HERD...
WITH THE POWER AND CUNNING
BORN OF LONG EXPERIENCE,
SHE'S LIKE A HEAT
SEEKING MISSILE.
♪ ♪
THIS IS A SLIPPERY SLOPE.
[BIRDS CAWING]
THE DEATH OF THE ELK CALF
MEANS A REPRIEVE FOR
OUR PREGNANT BISON...
BUT FOR HOW LONG?
[HOWL]
IN WINTER, THE ALCHEMY OF
HEAT BELOW AND COLD ABOVE
MAKES YELLOWSTONE LOOK
LIKE A DIFFERENT PLANET.
EVEN AT 50 DEGREES BELOW,
THERE'S MAGIC IN THE AIR.
♪ ♪
EXTREME SUB-ZERO TEMPERATURES
IN A CLOUDLESS SKY SOMETIMES
RESULT IN A
FASCINATING PHENOMENON:
THE FORMATION OF
DELICATE ICE CRYSTALS...
KNOWN AS "DIAMOND DUST".
SOME BISON HAVE
DEVISED A SPECIAL STRATEGY.
HOT SPRINGS GIVE OFF HEAT,
ENABLING GRASS TO GROW.
A HASSLE-FREE SPA PACKAGE AT
MINUS 20 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT.
WINTER IS IN SLOW RETREAT,
IN YELLOWSTONE'S
OWN GRAND CANYON.
WARMER TEMPERATURES
UNLEASH THE FROZEN LOWER FALLS,
TWICE THE HEIGHT OF NIAGARA.
AND SOMEONE ELSE
IS BEING UNLEASHED, TOO.
JUST OUT OF HIBERNATION,
A YOUNG BEAR CAN'T
RESIST THE AROMA...
OF FRESH CARRION.
A SECOND GRIZZLY
HAS BEATEN HIM TO IT...
THE CARCASS OF YET
ANOTHER BISON THAT DIDN'T
MAKE IT THROUGH THE WINTER.
AFTER SPENDING MORE THAN
FOUR MONTHS IN THEIR DENS,
THEY'RE EAGER TO
FIND SOME FOOD.
BEARS LOSE UP TO A THIRD
OF THEIR BODY WEIGHT
DURING HIBERNATION.
AND THEY'RE RAVENOUS.
SOMETHING'S GOTTA GIVE.
GRIZZLIES WOULD RATHER
INTIMIDATE THAN FIGHT;
THERE'S JUST TOO
MUCH RISK OF INJURY IN
BEAR-ON-BEAR VIOLENCE.
STANDING UP TO YOUR FULL
HEIGHT IS MEANT TO IMPRESS...
OOPS.
THE OWNER OF THE
CARCASS DECIDES TO SHOW HIM
HOW IT'S DONE.
BUT WHEN RITUALS FAIL...
VIOLENCE IS INEVITABLE.
NARRATOR: HUNGRY
BEARS ARE VIOLENT BEARS.
♪ ♪
THE PAIR IS CLOSELY MATCHED
AND EQUALLY DESPERATE FOR A
POST-HIBERNATION FEAST.
A FIGHT LIKE THIS IS A
RARE SIGHT IN YELLOWSTONE.
[GROWLING]
WITH A FINAL SLAP,
THE NEWCOMER TELLS HIS
RIVAL TO "SHOVE OFF" AND
CLAIMS HIS GRISLY PRIZE.
SPRING IS FINALLY
HERE IN EARNEST.
IN THE VALLEYS, WARMER DAYS
EASILY SHRUG OFF LATE SNOWS.
IN THE PARK'S
NORTH-EAST LIES SODA BUTTE,
A LIMESTONE MOUND
CREATED BY A HOT SPRING.
A MUDDY CONDO COMPLEX OF
SORTS IS UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
AMERICAN CLIFF
SWALLOWS ARE BUSY NESTING...
THE MUD AT THE FOOT OF THE
CONE MAKES A PERFECT CEMENT.
BISON LOVE THE MUD
OF SODA BUTTE TOO,
BECAUSE IT'S RICH
WITH MINERALS....
MINERALS THAT THE
PREGNANT FEMALES CRAVE.
SOON THE VALLEYS OF
YELLOWSTONE WILL BE
FULL OF BABIES.
OUR MOTHER GROWS
RESTLESS AND NERVOUS.
WITH GOOD REASON.
DOWN THE VALLEY,
A PACK OF WOLVES HAS
FOUND A STILLBORN CALF,
BUT IT WILL ONLY
FEED ONE OR TWO OF THEM.
SO THE REST HAVE
TURNED ON THE MOTHER.
WEAK FROM HER ORDEAL,
SHE IS TOUGH...
BUT VULNERABLE.
SHE MAKES A
BREAK FOR THE HERD.
A RISKY DECISION.
EVEN WHEN SHE
REACHES THE HERD,
THE WOLVES DON'T GIVE UP:
BISON ARE MOST VULNERABLE TO
ATTACK FROM BEHIND...
FINALLY, THEY ROUND UP,
CREATING A SHAGGY,
IMPENETRABLE FORTRESS.
ON THE SLOPES ABOVE, OUR
HERD IS MISSING SOMEONE.
THE MOTHER HAS SLIPPED OFF
INTO THE BRUSH TO GIVE BIRTH.
THIS MOVING AND INTIMATE
MOMENT HAS RARELY BEEN SEEN
IN THE NATIONAL PARK.
♪ ♪
IMMEDIATELY THE LITTLE
ONE STARTS SQUIRMING FREE
FROM THE AMNIOTIC SAC.
HE'S ONE OF ABOUT 700 BISON
CALVES THAT WILL BE
BORN THIS YEAR.
THE MOTHER LOVINGLY
CLEANS HER CALF,
URGING HIM TO HIS FEET...
HE'LL NEED TO BE ABLE
TO RUN WITH THE HERD IN A
MATTER OF HOURS.
♪ ♪
HE'S UP ON WOBBLY
LEGS IN MINUTES....
ADORABLE AND OBLIVIOUS
TO THE ASTOUNDING STRUGGLE
THAT LIES AHEAD.
NARRATOR: IN THE
HIGHER ELEVATIONS,
WHERE THE SNOW STILL HANGS ON,
ANOTHER PREDATOR IS
STAGING A COMEBACK.
IT'S THE NOTORIOUSLY
SHY COUGAR,
ONE OF ONLY
ABOUT 20 IN THE PARK,
RETURNING TO HER ELK KILL.
THESE BIG CATS ARE SO
ELUSIVE EVEN PARK RANGERS
RARELY SPOT THEM.
AT ONE POINT THEY
WERE VIRTUALLY ELIMINATED
FROM YELLOWSTONE.
THE RAVEN SHOULD BE
CAREFUL ABOUT COMPLAINING.
COUGARS CAN LEAP
15 FEET STRAIGHT UP.
SHE'S NOT ALONE.
HER THREE-MONTH-OLD
KITTEN IS STILL NURSING BUT
DEVELOPING A TASTE FOR MEAT.
THE RAVEN'S A NOISY
IRRITANT AND IT COULD ALERT
RIVAL PREDATORS
TO THE KILL...
BUT SOMEONE'S
LATE TO DINNER.
♪ ♪
KITTENS WILL BE KITTENS,
NO MATTER HOW BIG.
OUTSIDE THE PARK,
COUGARS ARE STILL SHOT BY
THOSE WHO THINK THEY'RE
A THREAT TO LIVESTOCK.
BUT HERE THE
LITTLE FAMILY IS SAFE.
♪ ♪
YELLOWSTONE'S PART OF
THE ROCKIES USED TO BE
ON THE SEA FLOOR.
THE CLASH OF CONTINENTS
HAS DRIVEN THEM 8,000 FEET
INTO THE AIR.
BUT WHAT THE EARTH LIFTS,
WATER SLICES,
REVEALING THE YELLOW
ROCK CANYON THAT GIVES THE
PARK ITS NAME.
THE YELLOWSTONE RIVER,
THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE PARK,
POURS INTO THE VALLEYS.
THE HERD MUST MOVE IN
SEARCH OF BETTER GRAZING AND
OUR CALF IS
READY TO JOIN THEM.
JUST HOURS AFTER HIS BIRTH,
THIS 40-POUND
FELLA CAN KEEP UP WITH
HIS 1,000-POUND MOM.
HE'LL FOLLOW MOM ANYWHERE,
EVEN IF IT MIGHT BE
THE DEATH OF HIM.
OTHER CREATURES HAVE
NOT BEEN SO LUCKY.
WOLVES NO LONGER HUNT, BUT
SCAVENGE AT THEIR LEISURE.
NOT FAR AWAY, THE PACK FEASTS
ON STILL ANOTHER FALLEN BISON.
BUT SOMEONE'S GOTTEN
WIND OF THEIR BOUNTY.
A GRIZZLY MOTHER
AND THREE BIG CUBS.
RAISING TRIPLETS
IN YELLOWSTONE IS QUITE
THE ACCOMPLISHMENT.
EVEN AMONG GRIZZLIES,
WHO ARE NOTORIOUSLY GOOD
MOTHERS, SHE'S REMARKABLE.
WITH SO MANY MOUTHS TO FEED,
SHE HAS LITTLE CHOICE
BUT TO TAKE ON THE PACK.
♪ ♪
JUST WHEN IT LOOKS AS
THOUGH THERE'S ENOUGH
TO GO AROUND...
SOMEONE ELSE
IS ON THE SCENT.
A LONE MALE.
THIS IS BAD NEWS.
MALE GRIZZLIES
SOMETIMES KILL CUBS.
TIME FOR HIM TO BACK OFF.
A MALE BEAR, A YOUNGSTER,
IS NO MATCH FOR A
RILED-UP MAMA BEAR.
THESE WOLVES ARE
CONTENT TO WAIT,
WATCH AND AMUSE
THEMSELVES TILL THE BEARS
HAVE HAD THEIR FILL.
YELLOWSTONE IS THE ONLY
PLACE IN THE US WHERE BISON
HAVE LIVED CONTINUOUSLY
SINCE PREHISTORIC TIMES.
THEIR RELENTLESS SEARCH
FOR BETTER GRAZING GROUNDS
MEANS CROSSING RIVERS,
LIKE THE LAMAR...
CROSSINGS ARE NO BIG
DEAL FOR THE GROWN-UPS,
BUT A DAUNTING BUSINESS
FOR OUR 7-DAY-OLD CALF.
RUSHING SNOWMELT MAKES
THE LAMAR TREACHEROUS.
OUR LITTLE GUY IS
UNDERSTANDABLY DUBIOUS.
BUT WHEN MOTHER
MAKES HER MOVE,
HE HAS NO CHOICE
BUT TO FOLLOW.
AND ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
THINGS START TO GO WRONG.
THE CURRENT IS JUST TOO MUCH.
♪ ♪
HIS MOTHER TURNS BACK,
TRYING TO KEEP HIM SAFELY
UPSTREAM OF HER.
BUT THE WATER IS TOO SWIFT...
AND HE IS TOO YOUNG.
SHE REALIZES HER MISTAKE...
TOO LATE.
HE'S AT THE
MERCY OF THE RIVER.
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT
WILL DEFY BELIEF.
NARRATOR: A CALF SWEPT
AWAY BY THE LAMAR SHOULD HAVE
NO CHANCE OF SURVIVAL.
BUT SOMETHING
REMARKABLE HAS HAPPENED.
HE HAS WASHED UP ONTO
A LITTLE GRAVEL ISLAND.
HE'S CHILLED AND
UTTERLY SPENT...
AND MOTHER IS
NOWHERE IN SIGHT.
AS THE COLD
YELLOWSTONE NIGHT FALLS,
ALL SEEMS LOST...
♪ ♪
DAYBREAK REVEALS A WOLF
ON A KILL IN THE RIVER.
BUT IT'S AN ELK,
NOT OUR BISON CALF.
SOMEHOW, OUR LITTLE ONE
HAS SURVIVED THE NIGHT.
BUT HE'S STILL STRANDED.
ANY HOPE OF RESCUE SEEMS TO
BE MOVING ON WITH HIS HERD.
EVEN HIS MOTHER
SEEMS TO HAVE GIVEN UP.
THE INSTINCT TO STAY WITH
THE HERD IS OVERWHELMING.
AND THAT'S FOR
A GOOD REASON...
PREDATORS ARE
NEVER FAR AWAY;
SUCH AS COYOTES...
AND A LONE BLACK WOLF.
♪ ♪
BACK DOWNRIVER,
AGAINST ALL ODDS,
THE BISON CALF IS HOLDING ON.
BUT HE SEEMS OUT OF OPTIONS.
AND JUST WHEN THINGS
COULDN'T GET ANY WORSE...
THEY DO.
A STRAPPING YOUNG
WOLF HAS SPOTTED HIM.
THIS TINY ISLAND
OFFERS NO ESCAPE.
BUT APPARENTLY, OUR
CALF IS NO ORDINARY CALF.
HOPELESSLY OUTMATCHED,
WITH THE COURAGE OF INNOCENCE,
HE'S NOT GOING
DOWN WITHOUT A FIGHT.
AND THE INEXPERIENCED
WOLF FLAILS.
♪ ♪
AND THEN, A NOISE.
AN IMPOSSIBLE,
WONDERFUL NOISE.
HERE COMES THE CAVALRY.
BUT IS IT IN TIME?
NARRATOR: WITH AN ADULT
BISON CHARGING TO THE RESCUE,
OUR CALF NOW
TURNS ON THE WOLF.
♪ ♪
THE CALF SEEMS TO WONDER,
COULD THIS REALLY
BE HIS MOTHER?
IT SURE IS.
AND THE WOLF CAN'T
BELIEVE HIS EYES.
FAMISHED, THE PLUCKY
LITTLE FIGHTER LOSES NO TIME
FILLING UP ON HIS
MOTHER'S RICH MILK.
AND THIS WOLF HAS BEEN
THOROUGHLY BUFFALOED!
IN YELLOWSTONE, SECOND
CHANCES ARE HARD TO COME BY
AND IT'S GOOD TO BE ALIVE.
♪ ♪
SPRING RUSHES INTO
SUMMER AND THE PARK
SHOWS OFF ITS COLORS.
SUMMER IS A TRULY
GLORIOUS TIME IN YELLOWSTONE.
AND A GREAT TIME
TO BE A RIVER OTTER,
OR EVEN BETTER, A
PAIR OF OTTER BROTHERS.
TO SEE THESE GUYS IN
SUMMER IS A RARE TREAT.
RIGHT NOW, YUMMY
YELLOWSTONE CUTTHROAT TROUT
ARE FIGHTING THEIR WAY
UPSTREAM FROM LAKES TO SPAWN.
MORE THAN THREE MILLION
YELLOWSTONE CUTTHROAT TROUT
USED TO PLY THESE WATERS.
BUT THE ILLEGAL
INTRODUCTION OF LAKE TROUT
HAS DECIMATED THE POPULATION.
OTTERS LOVE FISH.
BROTHER HAS HIS LUNCH.
THE OTHER CAN'T
QUITE REEL HIS IN.
THIS SHOULD BE
LIKE FISH IN A BARREL.
FINALLY, SUCCESS!
BACK AT THE
SODA BUTTE CONDOS,
INSISTENT MOUTHS
GAPE AT EVERY DOOR.
THE CLIFF SWALLOW
PARENTS FRANTICALLY FEED
THEIR INSATIABLE OFFSPRING,
WHO WILL FLY THE
NEST IN JUST THREE WEEKS.
BUT SOMETIMES MOM AND
DAD ARE SO ENTHUSIASTIC...
EVEN THESE CHICKS CAN
GET A LITTLE UNGRATEFUL.
THE DAYS OF SUMMER
PASS ALL TOO QUICKLY, HERE.
YELLOWSTONE'S MAGNIFICENT
LANDSCAPES ARE A
STUDY IN CONTRASTS.
THIS PART OF THE
ROCKIES IS ANCIENT;
ABOUT 75 MILLION YEARS OLD.
BUT THE STEAMING PLAINS
ARE CONSTANTLY BEING REBORN,
THANKS TO THE
SUPER-VOLCANO SIMMERING BELOW.
HERE THE GUTS OF THE
PLANET ARE PERILOUSLY CLOSE
TO THE SURFACE.
GURGLING MUDPOTS
AND FUMAROLES,
LIKE THE RED SPOUTER IN
THE FOUNTAIN PAINT POT,
GIVE THE BAREST HINTS
OF THE POWER BENEATH.
BUT 640,000 YEARS AGO,
IT BLEW UP WITH THE FORCE
OF A THOUSAND ATOMIC BOMBS.
AND THE GEYSERS REMIND
US THAT IT FULLY INTENDS TO
BLOW UP AGAIN...
SOME SAY IT'S OVERDUE.
IT'S LATE SUMMER.
OUR CALF IS
PACKING ON POUNDS.
HIS RED COAT
IS TURNING BROWN.
THERE'S EVEN THE TINIEST HINT
OF A HUMP GROWING ON HIS BACK.
IT'S A BITTERSWEET
TIME FOR SOME.
OUR THREE GRIZZLY CUBS
HAVE BEEN DRIVEN OFF BY
THEIR ONCE-ATTENTIVE
MOTHER SO SHE CAN MATE AGAIN.
SHE DID HER JOB WELL,
THOUGH...
THEY'RE FAT AND STRONG.
THE LAKE PROVIDES RELIEF
FROM THE HEAT AND ADDS SOME
MUCH-NEEDED
GREENS TO THEIR DIETS.
THEY FILL UP ON
TASTY AQUATIC PLANTS.
♪ ♪
WATER FIGHTS ARE GOOD FUN,
AND GENTLE PRACTICE FOR
SETTLING SCORES LATER ON.
THE TRIPLETS WILL SOON
GO THEIR SEPARATE WAYS,
TO FACE THEIR
FIRST WINTER ALONE.
AT THE LARGEST THERMAL
FEATURE IN THE PARK,
THINGS ARE HEATING UP.
THE GRAND PRISMATIC SPRING
GETS ITS VIVID COLORS FROM
A RAINBOW OF
HEAT-LOVING BACTERIA.
AND THE PLAINS NEARBY ARE
ABOUT TO HOST A SPECTACLE.
THE BULLS ARE GATHERING.
SOON THE FLATS WILL
REVERBERATE WITH THE THUNDER
OF HOOVES AND THE
CRACK OF MIGHTY SKULLS.
THE RUT IS ABOUT TO BEGIN.
NARRATOR: THE BISON RUT
IS SHEER PANDEMONIUM.
SNORTING AND SNUFFLING,
BELLOWING AND BELCHING MEANS
THE AIR IS THICK
WITH TESTOSTERONE.
THERE'S A GOOD DEAL OF
COMPETITIVE WALLOWING...
BATHING IN DUST AND
ROLLING IN THEIR OWN URINE
TO INTIMIDATE RIVALS.
NOW FOR THE DOGGED
PURSUIT OF THE FEMALES.
EACH DAY BRINGS MORE
BULLS TO THE VALLEY,
LURED BY THE SCENTS AND
SOUNDS OF PROCREATION.
MATING IS A QUICK AND
UNROMANTIC BUSINESS.
IF IT TAKES, SHE'LL
CARRY THE BABY FOR NINE MONTHS
THROUGH THE
MERCILESS WINTER AHEAD.
TANGY HORMONES
DRIFT ON THE BREEZE.
THE BULL IS ALREADY
CHECKING THE NEXT FEMALE:
HE SAVORS HER
READINESS WITH A LIP-CURL.
BUT THERE'S
TROUBLE ON THE HORIZON.
A ONE TON LIVING
MOUNTAIN OF MUSCLE AND SKULL.
AND HE'S READY TO RUMBLE.
THE CHALLENGE
MUST BE ANSWERED.
HIGH NOON IN THE
YELLOWSTONE CORRAL.
THEIR MASSIVE
HEADS AND NECKS ARE
BIOLOGICALLY ENGINEERED
TO ABSORB ENORMOUS IMPACTS.
♪ ♪
NOW THERE'S A
NEW SHERIFF IN TOWN.
OUR CALF, A TOUGH
LITTLE SURVIVOR,
IS BOUND TO TAKE HIS PLACE
AMONGST THE BULLS ONE DAY.
HE'S ALREADY SHOWN ENOUGH
COURAGE TO LAST A LIFETIME.
THE BISON RUT DRAWS TO
ITS END IN EARLY AUTUMN.
BY LATE SEPTEMBER...
THE FALL SUN SETS
THE TETONS BLAZING.
♪ ♪
WHILE THE MOOSE
FATTEN UP FOR THE WINTER,
THE ELK ANNOUNCE
THEIR OWN RUT HAS COME.
THEN, THE PLACE
FALLS SILENT;
THE BISON ENJOY A LAST
FEW MOMENTS OF PEACE BEFORE
THE ONSLAUGHT OF WINTER.
NOW ONLY THE VOLCANO
BELOW MAKES ITSELF HEARD.
A REMINDER OF THE ENGINE THAT
POWERS AND PROTECTS THIS PLACE
AND THE MAGNIFICENT
CREATURES WE ALMOST LOST.
IN AMERICA'S
OLDEST NATIONAL PARK.
YELLOWSTONE.